ابو ابن الشرافي وهو معنا من من رفح كيف
يبدو الوضع الانساني يعني هناك تصريح
لبوري يقول بانه حوالي مليون و400 الف من
الفلسطينيين في رفح يعانون من
خطر المجاعه كيف تبدو الاوضاع الانسانيه
في
رفح نعم جمال هي اوضاع كارثيه للغايه في
مدينه رفع نتحدث عن مليون و300 ال نازح
الى جانب 100
الف نسمه من سكان مدينه رفح الاصليين اي
ما يعادل مليون ونصف انسان يعيشون في هذه
المدينه التي تبلغ مساحتها 55 م اي اي اي
اي اي يعيش في كل كيلومتر مربع واحد 27000
انسان واي عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه او قصف
اسرائيلي بالتاكيد حتما سيوقع المزيد من
من الضحايا الاوضاع الانسانيه هي اوضاع
كارثيه للغايه كما ذكرت هناك هناك لا
تتوفر مواد تموينيه للسكان والنازحين
وايضا هناك معاناه في توفير المواد الطبيه
وتفشي الامراض في صفوف النازحين تحديدا في
مراكز الايواء التي امتلات عن بكره ابيها
في التابعه
للانرويد في الساحات والشوارع العامه في
ظل نقص حاد في الادويه وتوفير الرعايه
الطبيه هناك مناشدات بضروره ادخال مزيد من
المساعدات لهذه الاعداد الكبيره من
النازحين التي تعيش في مدينه رفح وايضا في
ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي والغارات
الاسرائيليه خلال ال8 ساعه نتحدث عن اكثر
من 30 شهيدا في مدينه رفع نتيجه غارات
اسرائيليه استهدفت منازل في مناطق متفرقه
من المدينه اكثر من نصفهم هم من عائلات
نزحت من المنطقه الشماليه وم مدينه غزه
الى مدينه رفح تحت الدعاء من قبل جيش
الاحتلال انها منطقه امنه في حين ان
الغارات والقصف الاسرائيلي يستهدف كافه
المناطق في رفح وحتى المنطقه الحدوديه مع
مصر شهدت سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي استهدفت اراضي زراعيه وهي قريبه
ومتاخرات ايواء للج للنازحين التي تضم
مئات الالاف من العائلات في العراء في تلك
المنطقه
الحدوديه شكرا لك مؤمن الشرافي مراسل
الجزيره متحدث من رفح وشكرا كذلك ل